the criminal justice system is filled  with arcane legal terminology  laypeople often use this vernacular  incorrectly habeas corpus  they say bad  law  words  incredibly exact but we can make these  bad law words good  what actually is a chicken there's a  whole debate over whether a hot dog is a  sandwich that's generally how lay people  sound when they're using legal concepts  that defines a tomato as a fruit even  though we all know a tomato is a  vegetable  malice a forethought good samaritan law  an offense against all the people  [Music]  right off the bat is begging the  question a catch-22 the bed of  procrustis imminent and eminent insure  versus insure and then there's forgo  versus for go because i'm informed that  some of you actually  are not lawyers and that saddens me  so welcome  to bad law words good  legal eagle  you